time travel finger guns and buzzing
electricity no better call saul didn't
become a science fiction series in its
finale but it did give longtime fans
plenty to ponder
at the start of season six a worn
paperback copy of h.g wells the time
machine is confiscated from saul
goodman's abandoned mansion it's only
fitting that in the series finale both
that book and the notion of time travel
return in flashbacks to key moments with
mike ermantraut walter white and jimmy's
brother chuck while on their desert trek
with lalo's money from season five's
bagman jimmy asks mike what he would do
if he had a time machine he poses the
same question to walt while they await
getting disappeared by ed the vacuum
cleaner repairman during the events of
the breaking bad episode granite state
mike unsurprisingly thinks of his doomed
son maddie and the first time he ever
took a bribe walt however scoffs at the
very idea of time travel saying
you are talking about regrets so if you
want to ask
about regrets just
ask about regrets
jimmy gives mike and walt shallow
answers to his own question but the real
answer seemingly comes in the third
flashback as jimmy stocks groceries for
his brother jimmy and chuck's
relationship was always contentious with
jimmy often straining for chuck's
approval and love while not quite
getting it this time it's chuck who
makes an effort to reach out and jimmy
who refuses it there's no shame in going
back and changing your path
oh
when have you ever changed your path he
also leaves chuck alone to read the time
machine by lantern light if jimmy had
accepted that small olive branch who
knows how things might have turned out
wayfarer airlines flight 515 is an
important part of the breaking bad
mythology the plane's fate was a symbol
of the way walter white's actions had
terrible unexpected consequences his
decision to let jesse's girlfriend jane
die leads to her father an air traffic
controller inadvertently caused a
mid-air collision that rains down debris
over albuquerque
stylistically the event coined many of
the elements that breaking bad and
better call saul would be known for with
evocative black and white prologues
flashing forward to the disaster and a
secret message hidden in the episode
titles the wayfarer disaster was also
something that saw goodman milked for
all it was worth wearing a memorial
ribbon on his lapel for the remainder of
breaking bad in the better call cell
finale he's extradited back to new
mexico to stand trial for his many
crimes flying with the u.s marshal
aboard a wayfarer flight later he enters
the courtroom resplendent in a shiny
saul goodman suit complete with a
wayfarer ribbon pinned to the lapel
the ghost of chuck hangs heavy over the
series finale saul's final courtroom
performance has two major callbacks to
his late brother the most explicit comes
as saul torpedoes his plea deal by
admitting that he was not walter white's
unwitting victim but a willing
participant in his criminal empire that
night i saw opportunity
a shot at big money
saul soon finds himself talking about
chuck and the shot cuts to an angle high
above the courtroom behind an exit sign
buzzing with electricity that image is a
reminder of season three's chicanery in
which jimmy proves that chuck's
professed electromagnetic sensitivity
was a psychological condition the meat
of saul's speech in which he turns away
from a self-serving lie and faces the
truth calls to mind jimmy's testimony to
the bar association at the end of season
four there he tearfully invoked the name
of his brother as nothing more than a
con to get reinstated as a lawyer making
a fool of everyone listening including
kim his final performance reverses that
he praises chuck's brilliant legal mind
acknowledges his culpability in the
events that led to chuck's suicide and
reclaims his family name the name's
mcgill
i'm james mcgill
it's all sincere and it's all for kim
jimmy's plan all along was not to get
himself off the hook but to redeem
himself in her eyes
jimmy's seven year plea deal at a cushy
federal prison with a golf program goes
up in smoke replaced by an 86 year
sentence in a maximum security federal
prison but things could be worse he
finds himself working in the prison
cafeteria putting his cinnabon skills to
work baking bread his long tenure as
saul goodman has earned him the respect
of his fellow inmates and guards alike
who all refer to him by his famous alias
and thanks to an unexpected visitor he
gets to be jimmy mcgill once again if
only for the length of one smoke kim
shows up posing as his lawyer thanks to
her new mexico bar association id which
never expired the two of them share a
cigarette in near silence just like they
did in their very first scene together
as kim leaves likely for the last time
jimmy watches from the prison yard and
gives her the same finger guns that
ended season 4 and introduced the legal
world to saul goodman the same finger
guns kim gave at the end of season 5 as
she devised a plan to ruin howard hamlin
but while both of those gestures
signified the start of something
this one is a goodbye